hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast functional
characterization is gene regulatory
elements presented by doctor and Azov
audio a professor in the department of
bioengineering and therapeutic Sciences
and the Institute for energy not human
genetics at the University of California
at San Francisco we are excited to bring
you this educational webcast
presented by labrys I am Marjorie torres
of labs and I'll be your moderator for
today's event before we begin I would
like to remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the green Q&A button located in the
lower left of the presentation window
and type your questions in the box that
appears obviously well answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation also please notice
that will be viewing the presentation in
the slide window to enlarge your window
just click on the screen icon located on
the lower right if you have trouble
seeing or hearing this presentation
please click on the support button at
the top right of the presentation window
or use the Q&A button to let us know
that you're having a problem pretty sure
me in welcoming dr. Anna da bike you
will now turn the presentation over
again
hi and so it's a great pleasure to be
speaking here today and my lab is
interested in enhancers which could be
sort of simplified as being termed the
promoters of the promoter so for example
right here we have an a gene that's
expressed in the limbs in the forebrain
and in the neural tube and then what
people have seen is that you just inject
the promoter and the gene itself you
don't get this complex expression
pattern and in the lens and a neural
tube and in the brain however if you
start injecting and much bigger chunks
of DNA you start getting these and
complex expression patterns because
there are DNA sequences called enhancers
that tell this gene to turn on in the
limb in a neural tube and in the brain
and these sequences are called enhancers
and function as the promoter of the
promoter telling the promoter when to
turn on what tissue to turn on and at
one end levels to express the gene
itself so why do we care about these
enhancers these regulatory elements well
if you have mutations in these
regulatory elements that tell genes want
to turn on and want to turn off that
could be phenotypes and some phenotypes
that could be involved with this is just
basic human variation how we're
different from one another
another is Union disease for example in
all formations which we'll discuss a
little bit later on but there's a lot of
other diseases that could be caused by
limb by mutations and enhancers and
finally morphological differences
between species it's not a lot of
differences in morphology between
species could be due to changes in gene
regulatory elements
so again why do we care about these well
currently now with the sequencing
technology becoming extremely cost
effective and then really
revolutionizing how we do things in
genomics and clinical evaluations and so
forth as you can see from this graph the
amount of sequence genomes is rapidly
rapidly decreasing and the sequencing
cost is rather rapidly being reduced and
so we can make millions of genomes and
in the future we'll have that a lot of
genomes being sequence and the problem
there is that when you sequence a genome
only 98% and sorry only 2% of it is
actually coding and 98% is non coding
and where these regulatory elements way
lies so just to illustrate this through
the slide only these two base pairs will
actually be coding exons and code for a
protein and all the rest of the genome
that we sequence is actually non-coding
where a lot of these enhancers and
regulatory elements play by where you
still don't really get a good
understanding of their function and what
they do in addition in terms of
variation whenever we sequence a genome
we get on average 3.5 million variants
and only a very small number of them is
actually in coding exons on 6% and again
to illustrate this here this would be
the small little red part of the C here
in terms of having variance in exons and
so we have this vast genomic space to
search for and regulatory elements and
in it most of the variation that we get
from sequencing genomes lies and we
really don't have the understanding of
it of what it does and in addition
non-coding regions as I mentioned before
it could be a major source of variation
and disease a lot of genome-wide
Association studies have found a lot of
the associations with variants in these
regulatory elements and human disease
many Mendelian studies classical ones
still did not find a lot of mutations in
coding sequence and so
are definitely mutations and having
found mutations and regulatory elements
that might lead to phenotypes and as I
mentioned the Union genome contains
thousands millions actually of
regulatory elements and enhancers and so
we are not that still not that great in
trying to tie mutation to the phenotype
and one of the main reasons for that is
that we don't have this regulatory code
so unlike genes when we know the
regulatory code and for example CCC
codes for prolene and we know the
consequences of nucleotide changes to
that code you change here a CPC to the
SRS CCC the CPC prolene cane solution
and that could lead to some sort of
phenotype but for regulatory elements we
don't have that so even if I was to find
a sequence that I know is an enhancer
and I see a nucleotide change in it I
really don't know what it's really on a
phonetic level at this stage and so
that's a really big problem for us in
the field and we can find variants now
in non-coding space but we really don't
have a good understanding of what
they're doing and how they lead to
phenotypes and just to illustrate how
big of the problem this is I thought I'd
show an example probably the most common
example of an enhancer that actually
meets the human phenotype in this case
limb al permissions and just how much
little we know about how mutations in
this enhancer actually meet the human
phenotype in this case human disease so
here we have a gene called sonic
hedgehog and and mutations in the coding
region of this gene right here and lead
to a various and the need is a very
steam effect including holoprosencephaly
brain defects cyclopia kids are going
with one eye limb off formations a lot
of bad things in terms of coding
mutations and then 1 million base pairs
away in an intron of another gene
so this is a non-coding sequence that is
1 million base pairs away from the gene
that regulates there's the sonic catch
of the limb enhancers that tell sonic
hedgehog to turn on in the limb at a
specific time form if we can delete this
non-coding sequence in mice we get mice
that have truncated limbs as you can see
here compared to their wild type
littermates as you can see and on the
left of this so this clearly is a an
example of that a non-coding regulatory
element when you remove it leads to a
functional phenotype in this case
truncated limbs in addition if we
sequence and patients who have an extra
finger everybody who has an extra finger
in these families here has a point
mutation in the sonic hedgehog limb
enhancer and you can see that these
pointy patient's segregate nicely and
with this you know type itself there's
not all the 18 different point you
tations that have been found in humans
in this enhancer to actually lead to and
limb off formations in unions and so and
we can use these funky stations to try
to do we get a better understanding of
phenotype from genotype and as I'll show
you we're still very far away from that
so this is an example of a big Swedish
family that came into our lab that had
an extra finger and so the first thing
that was done was sequence this family
for the sonic hedgehog limb intense and
when we sequenced it because the
phenotype looks similar to these other
mutations that I showed you
we found a 13 base pair in surgeon in
all the affected cases so all of these
guys had the 13 base bearing surgeon
that was added and kida enhancer
and and so the next step and this isn't
all the affected members up there on the
top and so the next step is to try to
characterize what this thirteen base
permutation does now I would expect that
a circuit based care in surgeon would
lead to a much more drastic inner thighs
and a point mutation yet the phenotype
that we observed in this patient is
exactly identical to deploy mutations
that I showed you before so again and I
said the next step is to try to
characterize bump tell you what this
mutation might be doing one thing we can
do is look at what potential
transcription factor binding sites and
changes are there and you can see here
below that a lot of binding sites were
actually gained by having this 13 base
bearing surgeon and but not lost and so
it could be that there's now a lot of
things that bind through the sequence
that shouldn't bind but this is all in
silico predictions
you really don't know what it might be
doing in terms of a phenotype and so the
next step is to try to test this
function and the way we do this in the
lab is we have this an answer essay that
and we and a lot of other labs use where
we can clone for example the wild-type
Saudi ketchup immune enhancer sequence
here in front of a minimal promoter a
minimal promoter is like a light switch
that's always off if it has an enhancer
right here in front of it that will turn
on the minimal promoter and that will
turn on the reporter gene right here and
that will be something you can essay and
the reporter gene being something like a
GFP like ze luciferase or so forth we
can measure or look at the expression of
the reporter gene and see where it's
expressed and so we can take the
wild-type sequence as we do here for
this enhancer and in this case generate
in transgenic mice and see where this
enhancer is expressed it's expecting it
to be expressed in the limb similar to
what I've shown before and then we can
also take em the 13 base for insurgent
you stationed right here so we're
thinking exactly the same sequences
above but now with that 13 base for
inserting an into it and putting it
inside the same construct in front of
the minimal promoter and reporter deed
and asking the question is there a
difference between them if this gives us
the one on the top gives us a different
expression pattern versus the one in the
bottom in mice and so this is the
results for this so for the wild-type
sequence you see expression exactly
where sonic hedgehog is supposed to be
expressed as you can see here and in the
bottom of the limb right here now what
do we get for the and while for the
sorry for the 13 base bearing surgeon
when we do that we now see that sonic
hedgehog is potentially not only
expressed right here but also expressed
right here in these regions over here
suggesting that that's why we get this
extra finger here because it's not only
restricted to this side of the limb but
now also to the other side of the lid
and so this is great this functional
assay can give us a sense of what's
happening but it's very limited in
various ways one and each transgene has
a different number of insurgents of our
enhancer si vector and so it's really
not a quantitative si each embryo can
have different numbers of integration
and so we can't really measure
expression levels for this it can look
at differences in location in terms of
expression as we see here which is great
and but that will not be the case for
all and enhancers that there could be
differences in expression levels
quantitative differences which you can
essay in addition if for this enhancer
if there are two point irritations in
position 402 right here or 404 here that
has a much more severe phenotype we're
not only
you have an extra finger but also the
radius and the ulna are affected and
also the legs and these are pointy
patient's not a 13 based or in surgeon
and again I would expect a 13 base
bearing surgeon to have a much more
severe phenotype and a point mutation
but this is not the case and so here we
actually want to find the for ot
mutation and we did exactly the same
thing take that 4:02 mutation clone it a
right in front of the vector that I just
showed you here in front of the minimal
promoter and reporter gene and test it
in a mouse and when we do that you get
something like this which we do see
ectopic expression differences in
expression than what you see in the
wild-type but it really doesn't tell me
why this 403 mutation leads to a much
more severe phenotype compared to going
back here where this 13 base pair
insurgent and the expression pattern
that we see below leads to a less severe
phenotype of just having one finger
extra finger so all this is to say that
we're really not at the point where we
can really tell a phenotype from a
regulatory El Museo site and that's a
big problem for us and B so to sum this
up our current limitations is that we
have tons of genomic data that we're
getting from alga genome sequencing we
have a very limited understanding of the
regulatory code and you can find
mutations and known enhancers like I've
shown you for the sonic hedgehog lemon
tensor it's really hard to make sense of
what they're doing on the phenotypic
level and finally we have this very
limited functional assay that really
doesn't give us a good read out of
quantitive readout and more importantly
we're testing a sequence every time a
one by one by one here so you can only
quote in one sequence here while we're
finding millions of variants in the
genomes that we're sequencing and so
it's very limited also in terms of the
three
but that we can't use it to really test
thousands of the very millions of
experience that we are finding in
patients and so this really needs to be
improved upon and so in order to do that
we've been collaborating in the past
five years with the labs of annotation
guru and that's the work that I'll show
you today in the University of
Washington and also with Brett Cooper
and cuts and alpha and Daniela Witten
also mu dub and the work I'll show you
is done primarily by two very talented
post-op spawn in my lab we duck I know
what we did a lot of the experimental
and functional work and marking
character who did all the beautiful
computational analysis that I'll show
you in a minute and so the idea is was
to develop a sa that can allow to test
thousands of sequences for enhancer
activity instead of testing them one by
one as I shown you before so in order to
do that what we could do is again start
with the same vector that we have before
where we clone an enhancer in front of a
minimal promoter and reporter gene but
the trick is which adjacent or pioneered
was to add a 15 base pair barcode right
here on the right so this is a 15 base
pair sequence that can be transcribed
along with the reporter gene so if this
sequence on the left is an enhancer it
turns on the mineral promoter turns on
the reporter gene and will make an RNA
that has both the reporter gene and a 15
base card barcode and so that case you
can start cloning thousands of different
enhancers right here on the left and
then thousands of different barcodes on
the right and with paired end reads
where you can sequence the same DNA
sequence from the right and from the
left you can basically assign which
barcode goes with which enhancer right
here on the left and so you can know
when you build the library
what barcode goes with what enhancer and
so in that case you can clone thousands
of enhancers thousands of barcodes know
which one they are
and your readout to be RNA of if that
barcode is being expressed and so we can
take this library after we clone it and
stick it for example into cells via
transfection or other ways or stick it
into mice as I'll show you a bit later
on and then basically sequence both the
DNA to see if things went into the cells
or went into the mouse and then sequence
RNA you see if they're expressed which
will give us a quantitive read out
whether this enhancer is functional so
the RNA gives us is it functional and
the DNA tells us did it go into the
cells so if it didn't go into the cells
you know we can use it for an analysis
and so the readout could look something
like this
where for example if we look at this red
enhancer we've got DNA into the cell so
we know this went in and and we saw a
lot of RNA versus DNA for it in these
cells the will yellow one right here
you saw DNA so we know it lend it to the
cell but we didn't see a lot of RNA
suggesting that it's not a strong
enhancer and so forth and so on so using
this technology again you can test
thousands of sequences for enhancer
activity and thousands of variants also
so we've published on this a few various
articles and what I thought I'll do is
show you a bit of what we are doing this
in with this now currently in present
that is still some of it unpublished and
some of what we have published in the
past just to illustrate the strength of
this technology and so one thing that
you can do with this technology is
instead of taking and thousands of
different enhancers here on the left as
you can see here you can take and one
enhancer and just do thousands of
different mutations on it so in every
position if you have for example in one
position and a you can
to the C to a C or a G so you have
basically thousands of different
combinations of mutations that could be
in that enhancer and what that can give
you is a really better understanding of
where the function is where if I use a
is that reduce or increase enhancer
activity through this and then we can
take all this library and again and what
we've done in the examples I've shown
you is gone into cell lines as you can
see here and then test DNA and RNA and
see what mutations disrupt or the
enhancer activity or make it a better
and answer in either case and so we have
a big project where we took ten
promoters all listed here on the top and
ten enhancers listed here in red on the
bottom that are known to lead to various
human diseases and the diseases are
variable you can see for example the
hemoglobin promoters of these in
thalassemia and turret promoters are
leads to cancer a lot of various and
promoters and in various diseases and
same thing below for enhancers you can
see a lot of various enhancers that are
known mutations in them are known to
lead to you disease including the sonic
touch of lemon hamster that I mentioned
before in terms of that so we take all
these enhancers and all these promoters
make tons of mutations on them and then
clone it into this library and see how
the mutations affect the enhancer
activity by measuring the barcode that's
associated with the mutation and so I'll
just show you one example for this and
this is for the tert promoter that's a
long race promoter that is known to be
associated with a lot of cancers so the
third promoter and you tations in it are
actually extremely common in some kind
of types of cancer so mutations in
either position and minus 146 a GPA
change right here or mutations
position - 124 GPA mutation there either
one of these are extremely common in
some cancers so in 83 percent of
believable of stomas you would find
either the minus 1.8 4 or minus 1 46
mutation 71 percent of melanomas will
either have the minus 124 or minus 146
evasions
so these mutations either one of these
two are extremely common and what they
do is actually activate the third
promoter make telomerase active which
allows for cancer progression and so we
decided to see how mutations look at
this promoter and took basically the
promoter cloned it and did a lot of
mutations on it to see how they affect
the activity of this promoter and this
is the output that we get from studies
so you can see right here and this line
in the middle
insert the wild-type expression and so
anything that goes above this line means
that something is more active and
anything that goes below this line means
that it basically reduces the enhancer
activity as you can see here so for
example these two mutations right here
this one and this one right here are
actually the strongest mutations that
affect the most in terms of enhancer
activity has the height at the highest
effect and both of these are actually
activating mutations that activate the
enhancer and surprisingly enough these
are exactly the same two mutations that
I mentioned here - 146 and - 1.4 which
are the activating mutations that you
find in a glioblastoma and so these are
one serve as a great control to show
that RSA's can find that mutations that
have a synthetic effect but in addition
you see a lot of other mutations that
are activating like these ones or these
ones over here and some patients
actually don't have the two that I
mentioned before - 146
- 1:24 but may have these other
mutations in these other activating
positions and so having this data set we
hope will be very useful for clinicians
that can go and look at this data set if
we find a new mutation and see what it
does on a functional level in terms of
the activation of the third promoter in
addition there's a lot of in activating
mutation this region in particular gear
is of extreme interest as it actually
reduces and the enhancers I sorry the
promoter activity of turd and so if we
can figure out for example what
transcription factor might be binding
here and in this region over here and we
might be able to use an antagonist for
it as a way to treat patients who have
activating mutations if we can mess up
the binding of a transcription factor to
this region right here below you will
get lower activation levels for turret
and that will counter the higher might
be able to counter the higher activation
levels that you get from these mutations
above and so we hope that having this M
map of mutations not only for this
promoter but for a lot of other
promoters are known because disease and
a lot of other enhancers we will be much
smarter in terms of understanding what
these mutations are doing and in
addition we both at the community will
use these data sets to they predict and
build better computational predictions
of how mutations in gene regulatory
elements could be two phenotypes and and
what specific mutations can really have
an effect on a certain promoter or on a
certain enhancer in this case we've
tried a little bit to do that and I'll
show you one example and this is work by
marking character where he took for
example the tert promoter and try to see
can be predict where the positive and
the strong mutations are based on
various tools that are available
currently like a conservation - like CAD
F on seek and encode data
and so forth and I won't bore you too
much with this but what you can clearly
see from this is that we're still not
there yet that the current available
animations and scores are currently
insufficient to really give us good
predictions of how these mutations
affect the promoter activity here and
also in the other promoters and
enhancers that are shown you and as I
said we hope that having this data set
can be helpful in terms of trying to
better predict what these mutations are
doing in the future so this is and what
I've shown you is taking one enhancer
and basically doing tons of different
mutations on it another option if we
don't know a certain language is to
start building a language from scratch
if and seeing what works what doesn't
and so for example taking a synthetic
sequence and starting to throw for
example different transcription factor
binding sites so for example in this
illustration here it's this blue and
lime here is a transcription factor you
can take a neutral sequence like this
one here that we know is not an enhancer
and throw a blue transcription factor on
it let's say a green one here and a red
one here and ask the question does this
make it an enhancer or not so by
building language from the ground up and
asking different questions we can try to
get a better understanding of the
regulatory code and the grammar that
used for this code and through that
hopefully learn more again and get a
better understanding of and genotype and
phenotype in terms of regulatory
elements in this case and so for this
project and we took 12 different liver
transcription factor binding sites and
the main idea is and you really don't
have to understand everything that's in
this slide is that we took 12 different
transcription factors that are known to
be active in the liver this is a list of
all these 12 right here and for each one
we took a certain sequence
we know that they like to bind you as
you can see here we then generated and
5000 different sequences that are 168
base pairs long
on T neutral templates that had these
transcription factors and I'll walk
slowly through this so basically we took
T sequences that are neutral that we
know are not River enhancers in this
case and then we start throwing
transcription factor binding sites on
them to see does that make it an
enhancer or not so for example we take
the neutral sequence knows not a letter
enhancer and then we put one
transcription factor binding site right
here on the left on sorry on the right
and ask is it an enhancer or not where
we put a different at the same
transcription factor but now on the left
and ask is it an enhancer or not or we
can put for example two different
transcription factor binding sites or
eight different transcription factor
binding sites of the same transcription
factors each time we're taking just one
here for neville fox a one right here
and just throwing it on the neutral
sequence and asking the question is it
an enhancer or not and you use to
neutral sequences so we can compare them
and see who we get similar results we
can also take two different
transcription factor binding sites so
for example we can take Fox a 1 here and
TVPA and put one basically and right
here on the left and another one right
here
on the right on the neutral sequence and
ask the question is that an enhancer or
not we could put two and two four and
four and so forth and again ask the
question are we getting and enhancers or
not or also shuffle them and play around
with the order in terms of playing
around with order a lot of our library
was devoted to that we can take in this
case and and you can see here three
different transcription factor binding
sites
put them on the neutral template and
then all we do is we shuffle them like a
deck of cards to see if order is
important for their enhancer activity in
this case so now we have basically this
library of and 5,000 different sequences
and all in with various different
transcription factor binding sites right
here and have barcodes that we link to
those synthetic sequences and then the
next step is and we in this case
tested these sites both in cell lines at
g2 cell lines which are litter cell
lines and also in the mouse as I'll show
you in a second so for the mouse there's
a technology that can be used to get
sequences nicely into the liver and
that's called the hydrodynamic tail vein
injection it basically involves
injecting a large volume of liquid and
10% of the mouse weight so it's a mouse
for example weighs 30 grams that's 3 ml
in a very short period of time into the
tail vein of the mouse 4 to 8 seconds
right here this is equivalent for
example to injecting 8 liters of liquid
into me at four to eight seconds and
what you get from that is very specific
liver expression as you can see here
where somebody injected GSP into the
liver of a mouse and you see if move
Mouse in this case and you see only
expression in the liver but very less or
hardly any expression anywhere else so
this technique is great for getting DNA
into the liver and testing things in a
mouse liver but it's not good for other
tissues if you're interested in liver
it's a great thing to use if you're
interested in other tissues it won't be
that great to get a lot of DNA into the
liver and the expression of the DNA G
wheat and the best at 8 and to 24 hours
as you can see right here and so what we
do in this case and I'm gonna sort go
back in here
is we take this library injected into a
mouse 24 hours later you get DNA and RNA
from the mouse measure that and then
check for the enhancer activity in this
case to see which synthetic sequence
works which one doesn't and through that
hopefully learn rules about and these
regulatory elements so going back here
forward the first thing that we can
observe is that and the more and binding
sites you have so this is going for one
all the way to eight the more binding
sites you have the stronger you are in
this case and the darker blue here like
this or this and means that you have
more different transcription factor
binding sites you not only have
transcription factor a let's say but you
also have B and C and D so the more
different transcription factor binding
sites the stronger you are so over all
we see is that the more transcription
factor binding sites that we put on the
sequence the stronger than answer is and
then the more different they are a
terrific as we call them the stronger
you are in terms of your enhancer
activity in terms of one transcription
factor binding site and what key is that
for some transcription factors for
example fear for action F 1 alpha if we
go from having one copy of the
transcription factor to eight copies we
get a much stronger enhancer so for all
these guys right here the more copies we
have the stronger we are which makes
sense but this is not the case for all
of them so in the case here below
there's a lot of transcription factors
that no matter how many copies we put we
still don't get a functional enhancer
suggesting that this serve rule exists
probably for some transcription factors
but not all of them in terms of two
transcription factor binding sites what
was nice is that we can you start a
looking at rules of interaction between
different transcription factor binding
sighs so for example here if we have and
this transcription factor Fox a1 and
this one right here NR 2 F 2 we have a
red line as you can see here between
them that means that they interact
better with one another and if you have
both of them together on that sequence
we're going to get a much stronger
enhancer and just having each one of
them separately so a lot of these
transcription factor binding sites like
to work with one another if you have
these red lines that you can see here
they basically like to work with one
another and then and we can also see
these black line right here towards xB P
1 and H and F 1 alpha and in this case
these key transcription factors we think
into sphere with one another and if we
have both of them on the sequence itself
we actually have reduced enhancer
activity compared to having each one of
them separately and so we can start
generating these maps of the is similar
to protein-protein interaction maps of
which transcription factors like to work
with one another and which ones do not
everything we did up to here is all
synthetic and only this earthen then the
synthetic world and so we wanted to see
are the rules in the grammar that we see
here relevant to and things that we see
in the wild and so in order to do that
we went to this data set generated in
Bing rent group and UCSD where they and
did a lot of genomics on the mouse liver
and in it through it and basically
predicted about 50 mm and liver
enhancers that exist in the mouse and so
we use this data set to look do we see
the interactions that you're seeing
right here that I showed you before do
you see these interactions much more
than what you'd expect by camps and reli
enhancers that exist in the wild and the
answer is yes so for seven out of the
eight interactions that I've shown you
they exist
more than you'd expect by canceled for
example if you look at Fox a1 and NR 2
f2 combinations of them you see them
much more and relight liver enhancers
than what you'd expect by chance
together suggesting that the grammatical
rules that we learned here the
combinations that we saw here actually
do this in the wild to make functional
liver and answers now the last part of
the library is made up of and various
transcription factors in order to ask
about order and we've done quite a lot
of this almost half the library was
actually tested for order and you can
see here by the number about 2600 and
sequences but I'll just show you one
example of this where we had and
different sets of a transcription factor
binding sites where mixed them around 49
combinations so for example beads
various 8 different transcription factor
binding sites we basically shuffle them
49 different times like a deck of cards
and so for example we could have this
sequence right here below that you see
here and that has exactly the state a
transcription factors of the one above
the only difference is the order of some
of these so for example if you look at
fox a1 it's not here now but it's more
on the right or if you look at H and f1
else though it's not here on the right
but now on the left right here and so
again we have exactly the same major
encryption factors the only difference
is that we shuffle them around and then
we ask the question is there a
difference in terms of the activity of
these and the answer is yes so for
example here the sequence right here on
the top is much stronger six full times
difference in terms of enhancer in the
verses the sequence right here on the
bottom suggesting that order is
important for enhancer activity and so
just to sum up this part not all
transcription factors increase
expression by having more copies as I
tell you some of them
even if we add more copies on the
sequence you don't get them to be strong
enough petrol tipic enhancer so
enhancers that have different
transcription factor binding sites
instead of having the same and
transcription factor binding sites which
you turn this homothetic and are tend to
be much stronger than ones that have the
same transcription factor all over again
so if you have different transcription
factor binding sites you tend to be a
stronger enhancer and then some
transcription factors like to work with
one another and some may interfere with
one another and that order is important
in terms of the transcription factors
and that it can affect the enhancer
activity and finally that grammatical
rules that we observe do seem to agree
up here in wild real life and enhancers
so the last part of this and of the
talking of this technology another thing
that we be doing in the past years is
trying to develop this technology to
work with lentivirus
and the advantage of lentiviruses
souffléd
one it can infect hard to trim SPECT
cell so cells that are really hard to
transparent for example and you can use
this technology unless you use Limpy
virus and so that Vantage of using lucky
virus is that we can actually go into
these cells and the second is that it
not only am a infects ourselves but it
integrates into the genome and so we can
measure the enhancer activity of
something that's integrated within the
genome versus everything that I've shown
you until now that is non integrated
that is episome that doesn't actually go
into the genome and so it might not be
affected by the chromatin marks or other
things that could be involved when
things integrate into the genome and so
it's lengthy virus our first study was
to ask the question is there actually a
difference between things that integrate
versus things that don't most techniques
to try to find regulatory elements
enhancers like chip seek attack seek and
others and no worries about which
technique here that is used or so forth
but most of them find enhancers in the
genome in Chrome
and and most of the characterization
just like the ones I've shown you before
the we've done is episomal it's done
outside the genome and so we basically
wanted to see if there a difference
between the enhancer activity for things
that integrate into the genome versus
things that don't integrate into the
genome for this and with lengthy also
you can really ask this question nicely
as is illustrated right here and so and
one thing that you can do here is
basically take a library and into the
case which we've done here of about and
2,300 enhancers that we think are liver
enhancers in this case and we clone it
along with the barcodes exactly like
I've shown you before with lentivirus we
also put in on this side right here and
on this side right here what is called
an T regressors that can protect it from
integration effects lentivirus can
randomly integrate into the genome and
there are chances that it might
integrate next to another enhancer and
that might steer result that might turn
on this construct and a gives you
complete a different results or it might
integrate into a silenced creaking or
reading that silence and might not turn
on at all and so the use of an T
repressors here on either side might
protect from where it integrates and
might sort of give it serve an
independent environment on either side
in addition we cloned here 100 barcodes
for each sequence so if we have for
example sequence aid that we're testing
for enhancer activity we'd have a
hundred copies of it with a hundred
different barcodes that go along with
the ride and so if one copy of it for
example integrates into the stylus
region we still have 99 other copies
that hopefully will not be silenced and
gives us some kind of measurement and
this also allows us to get a good
quantitative measurement so now we have
this library all cloned and make virus
and that can integrate into the genome
and then we can measure just like before
RNA
DNA and see the expression of this
what's nice with lengthy virus is that
we can also mutate that integrates the
enzyme that allows it to integrate into
the genome and so we can make a library
that has a mutant integrase that doesn't
allow it to integrate into the genome
and ask the question and what expression
pattern can get from this library so
what this allows us is actually to
compare apples with apples where we can
take the same exact library right here
on the top and test it in a non
integrating version right here versus an
integrating version right here and see
what differences do you see for exactly
the same library in terms of the
enhancer activity and so here on the
right I'm showing you the results from
three different replicas from each one
and there are first interesting
observation was that integrated
constructs so wild-type right here is
things that integrate that have a
wild-type
integrate and what we're doing here is
basically comparing each one of the
replication for example we compare
wild-type replicate one was like
regulated 2 we see that the results are
quite consistent and very similar
between the different replicates here on
the top we're comparing the mutant
libraries the ones that don't integrate
into the genome and as you can see here
they're a bit less consistent from one
another the more service what we really
wanted to do in this case is also
compare them to one another the
wild-type that want to integrate versus
one two don't integrate and if you look
here on the top and where it's
highlighted in green you can see that
there are major differences for example
here between wild-type to and mutant two
comparisons suggesting that there are
differences between integrated and non
integrated and enhancers they are quite
similar I mean you can see similarities
but as you can see here the similarity
is not perfect and there are definitely
differences between them and so we
wanted to see what drives these
differences and we've done a lot of
computational analysis and we Martin in
this case who analyzed a lot of the
differences that can be food and between
things that are active in wild type as
you can see here and versus things that
are enacted in mutant so here are the
things that make wild type active as you
can see here versus things that are
mutant and one main thing that we see
that made a big difference is the number
of transcription factors that a sequence
might have transcription factor binding
sites based on a chip seek datasets from
encode and other places and also we saw
a lot of enrichment for in things that
have binding sites for human thoughts or
else as you can see em right here and
and these are basically and cofactors so
transcription factors that bind together
to activate transcription and so what we
think is that cooperative binding having
different transcription factors binding
together to activate a expression is a
major factor and the major difference
between things that integrate versus
things that don't integrate and may
actually affect the expression levels of
enhancers in this study so just to sum
up and we basically have been developing
this technology of massively parallel
reporter essays and that allows us to
test we have different methods as I
shown you either by mutating one
enhancer and to death and seeing how
that affects it could be testing a lot
of different enhancers and seeing which
works and which doesn't and testing a
lot of variations in them or in testing
them in an integrated version using
lentivirus
or other and then using this technology
to get a better understanding of how
regulatory elements and genotype may be
to a certain phenotype
and we're not the only ones there's a
lot of other groups are using these
massively parallel recorder essays and
our main hope is that the more people
use these essays and the more people
publish data on these essays and that
will allow us to really get a better
understanding of how mutations and gene
regulatory elements commutes of human
disease and other phenotypes and rubies
and methods that I've mentioned and so
with that I just want to sum up and
thank and members of my lab and right
here on the left our collaborators and
UCSF here in the middle and our
collaborators in u-dub in particular
Taoiseach who is lab sit here on the
right and our funding resource use here
on the bottom and thank you very much
and I'll open it up for questions thank
you doctor are you tuned for that
informative presentation we will now
start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window tape
type your question in the box that
appears on your screen
and click on the send button will enter
as many of your questions as we have
time for let's get started our first
question is you get more than one
mutation in your saturation mutagenesis
Genesis experiment yes so the way we've
been doing sorry so the answer is yes
and so the way we've been doing these
mutations now is through error prone PCR
so we take the sequence the regular
wild-type sequence and we clone and TCR
it with a TAC polymerase that is prone
to making mutations and so we get a lot
of different mutations in that sequence
and so and technically if we sequence a
lot from the results we might be able to
get a sense of not only just how one
mutation effects and
is the but how combinations of mutations
can affect the activity of a certain
promoter or enhancer
I really have to and dig deep and do a
lot of sequencing and hope that we get
in the same sort of both mutations on
certain sequence or enough data that we
can basically try to model how that will
be did you serve any facing and the
synthesize enhancers so in terms of the
synthesized enhancers and we played
around as I've shown quite a lot with
spacing the distance between the
transcription factor binding sites and
we've done a lot of modeling can see
BCNU rules in terms of the distance
between them unfortunately we didn't see
anything in our models and that being
said it doesn't mean that spacing
doesn't have a difference here and we
were limited in the way that we clone
add these same sequences and to 168 base
pairs so we have a very short real
estate in terms of playing around with
distance and so they could definitely be
like we had a longer real estate or
thousands of more sequences we might see
an effect on the spacing but in this
case at least in our data we didn't see
any effect on spacing between these
transcription factors
we are almost out of time this will be
our last question
why are you limited to short sequences
in your synthetic enhancer and lengthy
wires contre yeah so the reason we are
limited to short sequences both in the
synthetic enhancers and lengthy fires
and vibrate that I showed you the way we
make these libraries currently the
cheapest way and make libraries and
synthesize DNA is through Legos and so
we can synthesize the Legos that are
about 130 base pairs in size and then
you can through Agilent we've been doing
two hundred and forty thousand of those
and that are two hundred and thirty and
base pairs in size and so that sort of
the easiest cheapest way who currently
synthesized things so especially in the
and synthesis example where we really
want to make sequences that don't exist
in the wild we tap the synthesize things
and then synthesizing the Legos really
makes it and the cheapest way to go and
test this thousands and thousands
sequences for their activity and so it
is a limitation a lot of enhancers could
be much bigger than that and we are
working on ways to trying to get much
longer sequences other groups have been
using a sequence capture so similar to
exome sequencing where you capture the
sequence and of the exomes to sequence
it you can capture a certain sequence
and clone it and test and that allows
you to get much bigger sequences and for
this but especially for the synthesizer
enhancers we cannot lose that technology
and really have to synthesize our own
DNA so it's a it's a limiting factor but
I'm sure with synthesis DNA synthesis is
becoming cheaper and better with time
hey we can improve on that and get
longer sequences
I would like to once again thank dr.
Nadal Phi 2 for his presentation I would
also like to thank laberd's for making
today's educational webcast possible
before we go I want to let everyone know
that today's webcast will be available
for on-demand viewing through August 11
2017 you will receive an email from
labrys letting me know when this webcast
will be available for replay please
share that announcements with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event that's all for now thank you
for joining us and we hope to see you
again soon
you